[Music]
what did Donald Trump say to his wife
Melania Trump during the inauguration to
make her react in this way this is a
very visual segment so if you're
listening to the podcast or the radio
show please check out the YouTube clip
for this because the visual aspect to
this is everything people emailing me
saying David did you notice Donald
Trump's demeanor towards Melania Trump
during the inauguration he just seems
like a horrible person and we have now
isolated a little bit of video where it
is clear Melania Trump we can start
playing it for people Pat Melania Trump
is smiling and Donald Trump turns to her
and he says something and the look on
her face is just it's so crushing it is
absolutely soul-crushing and we don't
know what it is that Trump said to her
Trump clearly said something that that
I'd be I mean it just looks like it it
got to the heart of her soul Pat and
just destroyed her and to be willing to
do something like this in public says an
insane amount about Donald Trump and I
showed the video to many women and they
said David that's the look of a woman
who is very afraid and compared now this
side by side of how President Obama and
Michelle Obama related to each other
during the inauguration and keep an eye
on Trump and Melania who genuinely might
hate each other from what it what it
looks like here let's take a look at
this video and you'll just notice such a
drastically different demeanor as
Michelle Obama shows up next to her
husband and Trump I mean he just looks
barely even pleased to see his wife uh
and Trump is just sort of rude to his
wife constantly here he is walking in
front of and away from her on
inauguration day and Michelle and Barack
Obama had to sort of say her save her
and say here will escort you in we'll
take a look at that clip as well Donald
Trump just sort of turning around and
saying hey okay I'm the president I'm
walking in Melania Trump is totally left
behind and Barack and Michelle Obama
they're having that to escort her in and
then again let's look one more time a
few times here at the Trump Melania
video
from turning he says something to her
and her smile just disappears and she
looks a combination of scared sad
embarrassed and ashamed
what could trump possibly said to her
there when you see this video do you
think it's more likely or less likely
that the countless sexual assault
allegations about Donald Trump are true
he just genuinely doesn't seem like a
nice guy does he yeah it could have been
just a quick insult or some kind of
quick comment I mean these people are on
film for the entire day there so I think
sometimes these pictures and video clips
can be deceiving but I think you can
kind of recognize that look when you see
one yeah I mean when you are on the
world stage and you turn to your wife
and say something that visibly crushes
her soul in this way what are you doing
in private that's the question that I
come away with Warby Parker is offering
a free five day home Tryon to give you
the opportunity to check out their
glasses I personally wear Warby Parker
glasses when I'm not wearing my contact
lenses and I also started with one of
these free at home try ons of five pairs
of glasses you can get your free home
try on and support the david pakman show
at Warby Parker trial com slash TDP s I
don't really like going into glasses
stores and trying on glasses while the
sales person sort of hovers over me and
I like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs and I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I like the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like $300 for prescription glasses high
which is just insane
Warby Parker glasses start at $95 that's
what mine cost and for every pair of
glasses sold Warby Parker distributes a
pair of glasses to someone in need
you can try five pairs and see what you
like check out the at home trial and
support our show
I going to Warby Parker comm /t DPS it
costs nothing